all right so back to [ __ ] indigenous
people's day or the first
people's day um so so basically
it's indeed there's a so it says in
history that we learned about it's a
growing movement by native american
activists and our native americans are
all activists i mean we're they're late
well no i don't think they're
left with much of an option but to fight
for the tiny [ __ ] that we gave them
that's like i love how like when people
were yelling about the cleveland indians
and the washington redskins it's like
that wasn't native americans they don't
give a [ __ ]
like nobody that was all but i think it
be it finally became
when when enough white people were upset
about mascots native americans were like
oh well if this is the thing that's
gonna bring attention
to all the [ __ ] up [ __ ] you've done
together yeah it should have been named
the washington karen's
yeah oh dude i would have loved it could
you imagine in their helmets just had a
little blonde hair
it's just the nancy it's just the nancy
grace haircut like
on the side logo oh dude that would be
great
they're fight songs called can i speak
to your manager yeah can
i speak to your manager no
karen's go carriage and we're back with
the patriots down 14 to 7 to the cairns
karen's driving the ball all right yeah
dude it's
native americans were like oh cool yeah
you guys don't like that they call it
the indians
we never had a chance to voice our
opinions
you're like oh there's a bus buy and
you're like did you know that that
actually plot of land
belonged to the legal you know like
something where you're like whoa
[ __ ] that's pretty [ __ ] up win
hundreds of years ago and they're like
no
a hundred years ago yeah
your grandmother was like don't get me
started yeah because i
dated one he was great he would flip me
around on his horse
yeah i dated never calls you back that
was his name
mary sorry mary lou i just felt like
we didn't really hit it off the sun told
the coyote
to not call you like how they get out of
not calling back
i went to the river for a message but
realized that the snake had taken my
love for you it's like
what does that mean runs with storms it
means
having sex with your sister it means i'm
kind of over it
yeah just got to be like i i can't get
out of anything by just blaming it on
the [ __ ]
elements yeah just listen to this to the
soul of the of the world and you can
blame anything right
damn why did you show up and you go oh i
just felt like
the wind the uh yeah the soul of the
wind
told me to go home and take a nap
anytime i'm about to break up with a
girl i just start doing meditation and
yoga just so i can be like one with my
spirits to like blame it on that
yeah like i'm just really doing a lot of
inner work
not you it's my chakras say that it's
not right and yeah do you respect that
and she's like yeah now if you had
any native american blood you can tell
them that an eagle came and saw you
yeah and brought the spirit of the wind
and then yeah
yeah yeah i am destined for other [ __ ]
i don't think you can say it like that
but it's it's so [ __ ] up
because when you love colorado and stuff
like it's kind of what you're saying you
have to learn
the [ __ ] up parts what we're talking
about like with the
with the native americans and all that
kind of [ __ ] is it's they gave them land
dude i didn't think about this
until recently in fact it was i i think
what made me think of it was last time i
was on history hyenas
when i was in fifth grade in aurora
shout out mission viejo elementary
school shot them out road runners dude
yeah getting it done
mission video it just sounds like a good
burrito it is a mission
i'd like to mention vietnamese burrito
with extra guac can i do a mission viejo
with no beans
that's good that's pretty good and you
go you guys do quesadilla fresco on that
or what do you do are you
chihuahua cheese um but they
uh in fifth grade they took us
to a [ __ ] reservation wow to see how
life is on the reservation and there's
just other 10 year old kids there that
are like
hey yeah i remember being there i live
in your neighborhood that you would
never meet
no but i'm saying like they're not even
in my neighborhood we went to their
reservation dude
we went to eastern colorado oh so
there's no way
dude they don't put them in like [ __ ]
inglewood or [ __ ] littleton
yeah they put them in like far east like
sterling like [ __ ]
out and you go out there and it's like
dirty
dusty because it's not it's not by any
good land right
and you're just this 10 year old kid
looking at another 10 year old kid
and he's like yeah you know like i
remember they would like come up and see
us and we'd like
hey you know like kind of talking you
were ships to them they were like oh
a toyota child oh a yellow school bus
yeah it's not real but i always remember
the craziest thing
with an arrow yeah i'm like oh god a
couple of us came back without hair we
got scalped
but i remember getting on the bus and
being like
yo this is a field trip for us right
and we're going home yeah they just live
here
you kind of went to like a zoo for
humans yes that's exactly what i was
thinking yeah it's like a zoo for you
and they go you want to watch them feed
and yeah they want to be comfortable
with that
yeah but that's what look at how he eats
the chicken fingers yeah
with his tools are made from mammoth
bones but that's what the bureau of
indian affairs did
because they came in and they're like
hey they don't want this right
they're still they have some statues i
believe up in in germany
of uh some nazi stuff is still up there
just as a reminder the kids be like hey
that's not a part of our
we don't like that part of our history
i'm pretty sure that if you're german
you're aware of what went down in the
30s and 40s like wait what yeah what did
we do [ __ ] we did that
where that but you feel like you didn't
know but that feels like
yeah i really like oh man that's so
weird so grandpa was like a bad guy
yeah pretty bad but
[Laughter]
germany japan south
south africa yeah they do this thing
where they
acknowledge what they do america seems
special in the fact that we're just like
now what yeah they're like slavery and
you're like ah come on
yeah we're still bringing that up and
you're like i don't know native
americans
we put them on reservations and we're
like i mean we're really going to change
you from columbus day i like columbus we
can't call him columbus and you're like
i don't know maybe get him
fresh drinking water and then we can
call it columbus day yeah how about we
get him some [ __ ] decent
how about we just kind of help him out a
little and then we could call it [ __ ]
white dude with pink dick day yeah
all [ __ ] nuts we can get [ __ ] nuts
if we want to
but that's the only like woke
part of me is like why don't we help out
the people that are still
going through this [ __ ] could have put a
bra put a part of our tax money to help
them out and that's what it should be
but i guess it's just not
do my um i heard like the wokest [ __ ]
out of someone that's in their 60s where
i was like damn that's [ __ ] crazy i
haven't heard that
a republican a republican woman
was like yeah i call her a patriot yeah
she's a true patriot but
i would i would guess i'm not for sure
but
i know she voted for trump in 2016.
think
maybe she would vote for trump at 2020.
she was like
she smokes weed we were smoking weed and
she and she was like yeah i think
i think uh blacks and native americans
should be able to
get the license to sell legal weed like
i think that's what we should do
it's like give them the licensing to
sell to open dispensaries and stuff and
you're like
damn that's woke as far as because you
know what all
that would go a long way because i do
know when i went to giannis and i went
to germany
art history tour guide told us the
reason why jews have been able to
assimilate back into german society and
culture of course there's always
anti-semitism there's hate and racism
anywhere you go
against every group somebody doesn't
like somebody for some reason
you were talking about falling into uh
problems that have no effect on you
your boy went through a big phase of
eating edibles and reading up on the
sudanese civil war
and that uh that'll rock you yeah and
it's like it's horrible but it's like
there's horrible things happening all
day every day there's
so many people just the numbers are what
they are but they said
all the jerk not all one of the things
the german government did
is like in the 1950s they gave jewish
citizens money like a little bit of
money
we know this isn't going to solve the
problems sure but here's some money kind
of like reparations
to just be like we aren't sorry the new
german government like wants you here
and like
made it very easy for them to get
businesses and credit was like
apologetic as opposed to being like hey
that didn't happen the way you thought
it did but that's what you run into with
american
with especially with with american
thought and like the way our
that's the way we work is if you were to
give
uh blacks and native americans rights to
own dispensaries
immediately to be like well it's not a
free market is it
yeah then what do you do i never did
anything i never owned slaves i never
took land
why can't i have that i need a business
and it's like it's it's the selfishness
of american behavior that stops us from
doing this right we're just like
oh [ __ ] i need that what about me and
it's like
it's the collective we if we [ __ ]
help out the collective we
you'll probably be a little bit better
yeah i agree dude but people
that's some cuck [ __ ] it's yeah not on
this podcast edit that part out with
yeah
[ __ ] thought [ __ ] yeah all i'm saying
is i'm doing shows at sturgis this
saturday and sunday eat red meat take
the land that you want
yeah and and [ __ ] it till she's got a
second puss right bro yeah that's it guy
make him come thank you so much for
watching hope you enjoyed the last video
don't forget to tell your friends like
subscribe and turn on notifications
[Music]